[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
breaking down something that ron said
when he first met harry in the
philosopher's stone now
ron says a lot of things and some of
it's nonsense
and some of it is legitimate however
when harry and ron are on the hogwarts
express together
traveling to school for the first time
he said something that caught my
attention
what house your brother's in asked harry
gryffindor
said ron gloom seemed to be settling on
him again mum and dad were in it too
i don't know what they'll say if i'm not
i don't suppose ravenclaw would be too
bad but
imagine if they put me in slytherin
that's the house vol
i mean you know who was in yeah said ron
he flopped back into his seat looking
depressed when i read the statement for
the first time
no alarm bells went off because well i
didn't know the full story at that point
however after reading all the books and
watching all of the films
it became apparent that there is a bit
of a problem with ron's statement
it's well known that voldemort's
identity was unknown no one knew that he
was tom riddle
so how did ron know that he was in
slytherin
at that point in time ron was just a
little kid
how could he have known dumbledore
discusses voldemort's anonymity himself
in the next book very few people know
that lord voldemort was once called tom
middle
i taught him myself 50 years ago at
hogwarts
he disappeared after leaving the school
travelled far and wide
sank so deeply into the dark arts
consorted with the very worst of our
kind
underwent so many dangerous magical
transformations that when he resurfaced
as lord voldemort he was barely
recognizable
hardly anyone connected lord voldemort
with a clever handsome boy
who was once had boy here so again how
did ron know
furthermore if ron knew and he was just
a little kid then it must have been
common knowledge
the truth is that ron never knew that
voldemort was tom riddle
in fact no one really made the
connection between voldemort and tom
so how did people know that dark lord
himself was a slytherin
well i think he bragged about it
voldemort even at the height of his
power
had a track record of bragging about his
heritage and that's because he was a
descendant of school founder
salazar slytherin himself he was proud
of it
and he wanted people to know so he
didn't shy away from sharing his
hogwarts house
he only kept his original identity
hidden voldemort was so proud of his
heritage that he even called himself
lord voldemort heir of salazarin
indicating that he intended to keep the
slithering connection
even after he became lord voldemort this
is supported by the following quotes
now harry i'm going to teach you a
little lesson let's match the powers of
lord voldemort
heir of salazar slytherin against famous
harry potter and the best weapons
dumbledore can give him
also there will be no more sorting at
hogwarts school
said voldemort there will be no more
houses the emblem
shielding colours of my noble ancestor
salazar satherin
will suffice for everyone won't they
neville longbottom
so the answer to this question is simple
voldemort was a known and proud
slytherin who likely blagged about it
and though people didn't know which
slytherin student he was
it didn't matter and that's it for this
video
if you enjoy the content please consider
liking subscribing
to support the channel until next time
it is the unknown we fear when we look
upon death
and darkness nothing more
[Music]